.
JOHN ROBERTS, GOOD TO SPEND
MONDAY WITH YOU.
>> Jacqui: THANKS FOR HAVING ME,
JOHN.
I'M JACQUI HEINRICH IN FOR
SANDRA SMITH.
ABOUT THIS TIME LAST YEAR
YOUNGKIN MADE IT A POINT TO
LISTEN TO PARENTS AND EVENTUALLY
TOOK THEIR CONCERNS TO THE
GOVERNOR'S MANSION AND MANY OF
THE SAME ISSUES ARE CLEARLY ON
VOTER'S MINDS.
>> THE ECONOMY DEFINITELY IS THE
ISSUE.
>> BETWEEN INFLATION WITH EVERY,
LIKE PRICES OF EVERYTHING GOING
UP, ESPECIALLY RENT AND GAS.
>> REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS IS LIKE
MY TOP ISSUE.
>> THE BIG THING IS THE BORDER
POLICY, THAT'S AWFUL.
>> I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A
CRACKDOWN ON CRIME.
>> OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM, WITH
THE KIND OF EDUCATION PROBLEMS
WE ARE HAVING, THE FOCUS, SEEMS
TO BE ON FAR MORE THAN WHAT IT
SHOULD BE, IT'S NOT ON THE USUAL
READING, WRITING, ARITHMETIC.
>> EVEN MORE WORRIED ABOUT THE
YOUNG FAMILIES.
HOW CAN THEY HAVE THE GAS WHAT
IT IS AND THE PRICE OF MEET.
>> THE FOOD IS EXPENSIVE,
EVERYTHING IS GOING CRAZY, AND
STRESSED OUT.
>> John: AN ISSUE ACROSS
AMERICA.
VIRGINIA GOVERNOR GLENN
YOUNGKIN.
START OFF BY SAYING DEMOCRATS
HAD BEEN CLOSING THE GAP IN THE
GENERIC PREFERENCE POLL BUT
REPUBLICANS SEEM TO HAVE FOUND
SOME NEW MOMENTUM IN RECENT
DAYS.
THIS NEW COMMITMENT TO AMERICA
THAT KEVIN McCARTHY UNVEILED
LAST WEEK, DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
IS THE PRESCRIPTION FOR VICTORY
FOR THE REPUBLICANS IN NOVEMBER?
>> I DO BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON COMMON SENSE SOLUTIONS
TO THESE KITCHEN TABLE ISSUES
THAT VOTERS ACROSS AMERICA ARE
EXPRESSING AS YOU JUST SHARED,
WE SAW IT IN VIRGINIA LAST YEAR,
OF COURSE THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THINGS THAT REALLY
AREN'T WHAT IS AFFECTING PEOPLE
EVERY DAY.
AND IT IS, INFLATION, AND COST
OF LIVING, IT'S CRIME,
EDUCATION, IT'S THE REALITY THAT
THE BORDER IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY CRISIS THAT'S IMPACTING
ALL STATES.
VIRGINIA IS A BORDER STATE
BECAUSE OF THE FENTANYL
OVERDOSES WE ARE DEALING WITH.
THESE ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT
ISSUES THAT I THINK THE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES ARE
SHOWING THAT WE HAVE COMMON
SENSE SOLUTIONS TO AND AS I'VE
TRAVELED AROUND THE NATION AND
HAD A CHANCE TO VISIT WITH
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR CANDIDATES,
WHAT WE ARE ALSO ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE IS THAT STATES RUN
BY REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS HAVE
OUTPERFORMED STATES RUN BY
DEMOCRAT GOVERNORS IN AN
EXTRAORDINARY RATE.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT, OUTCOMES
IN SCHOOLS, SMALL BUSINESS
GROWTH.
THE REALITY, OF COURSE, IS THAT
EVEN A STATE LIKE VIRGINIA,
WHERE UNDER THE PREVIOUS
DEMOCRAT LEADERSHIP THERE WERE
47TH IN THE NATION IN JOB
RECOVERY COMING OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC AND IN THE LAST EIGHT
MONTHS, WE HAVE ROCKETED UP TO A
TOP 20 STATE IN JOB RECOVERY.
COMMON SENSE SOLUTIONS TO THE
MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES.
>> John: YOU SAID WHAT'S
IMPORTANT ARE ISSUES THAT PEOPLE
DEAL WITH ON THE DAY-TO-DAY
BASIS.
THE DEMOCRATS WOULD ARGUE
ABORTION IS AN ISSUE THAT MANY
WOMEN IN AMERICA DEAL WITH ON A
DAY-TO-DAY BASIS AND INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FOR THEM.
PUT UP ON THE SCREEN THE LATEST
POLL HOW REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS ARE AGAINST EACH
OTHER.
ECONOMY, REPUBLICANS CLEAR READ.
INFLATION, REPUBLICANS LEAD.
ABORTION FLIPS AROUND.
DEMOCRATS HAVE ABOUT THE SAME
PERCENTAGE AND THEN ON DOWN
THROUGH CRIME, EDUCATION,
SCHOOLS, CLIMATE CHANGE AND
IMMIGRATION.
REPUBLICANS NEED TO MAKE THIS
ELECTION ABOUT BREAD AND BUTTER
ISSUES.
BECAUSE THE ABORTION ISSUE FROM
THE DEMOCRATS IS WHAT CLOSED THE
GAP OVER THE LONG SUMMER
HOLIDAY.
WHAT CAN THE REPUBLICANS DO IN
THE NEXT SIX WEEKS TO TRY TO
STRETCH THAT LEAD BACK OUT
AGAIN?
IT WAS A BLOOD BATH FOR THE
REPUBLICANS AGAINST THE
DEMOCRATS UNTIL THAT DOBBS
DECISION CAME OUT.
>> LET ME BEGIN WITH THE FACT
THAT EVEN IN MY ELECTION LAST
YEAR, MY OPPONENT TRIED TO MAKE
THE ENTIRE ELECTION ABOUT
ABORTION.
AND OF COURSE, IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT I SHIED AWAY
FROM, I MEAN -- VIRGINIANS
ELECTED A PRO LIFE GOVERNOR.
OF COURSE THE REALITY IS THAT MY
OPPONENT AND THE LEFT LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS ARE THE ONES WITH THE
EXTREME VIEWS.
IT IS EXTREME TO PROMOTE
ABORTION ALL THE WAY UP THROUGH
AND INCLUDING BIRTH, PAID FOR
WITH TAXPAYER MONEY AND IN
VIRGINIA, THEY EXPRESSED FEWER
ABORTIONS AS OPPOSED TO MORE AND
UP THROUGH BIRTH IS RADICAL, AND
I THINK AMERICANS BELIEVE THAT
AS WELL AND THAT'S THE MESSAGE
THAT REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES NEED
TO CARRY CLEARLY.
YOU ARE 100% RIGHT.
AS WE HEAD INTO THE NOVEMBER 8TH
ELECTION, AND BY THE WAY, IN
VIRGINIA, WE ARE IN EARLY
VOTING, VOTERS ARE FOCUSSING ON
THE ISSUES THEY CARE MOST ABOUT,
AND POCKET BOOK ISSUES AND RUN
AWAY INFLATION THAT REALLY
REPRESENTS THE FAILED BIDEN
PRESIDENCY WHEN IT COMES TO
MANAGING OUR ECONOMY, CRIME,
WHICH REPRESENTS THE FUNDAMENTAL
BELIEF FROM PROGRESSIVE LIBELS
THAT YOU BRING FEWER RESOURCES
AS OPPOSED TO MORE RESOURCES AND
GUESS WHAT, CRIME GOES UP, AND
EDUCATION, EDUCATION AS EVERYONE
IS BACK IN SCHOOL, TAKING ITS
PLACE AS A TOP ISSUE.
WE SAW IT IN VIRGINIA, AND LET
BE CLEAR.
PARENTS MATTER.
IT'S NOT A REPUBLICAN VERSUS
DEMOCRAT ISSUE, THIS IS A PARENT
ISSUE, AND WE WILL SEE EDUCATION
PLAY A HUGE ROLE IN THE OUTCOME
OF THIS ELECTION.
>> John: COME BACK TO CRIME YOU
MENTIONED A MOMENT AGO, MY
COLLEAGUE, KATIE PAVLICH, SHE
GOES ON THE NEXT DOOR APP AND
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN HER
NEIGHBORHOOD AND THEN --
>> DEFUNDING THE POLICE HAS TO
HAPPEN, WE NEED TO DEFUND THE
POLICE.
>> YES, I SUPPORT THE DEFUND
MOVEMENT.
>> TALKING ABOUT THE REDUCTION
OF OUR NYPD BUDGET.
>> NOT ONLY DO WE NEED TO DEFUND
BUT WE NEED TO DISMANTLE.
>> John: THAT WAS THE FAR LEFT
OF THE LEFT, NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS TRIED TO SAY
NO, I'M NOT FOR DEFUNDING THE
POLICE, I'M FOR FUNDING THE
POLICE, BUT DO THEY BASICALLY
OWN WHAT THE MEMBERS OF THE
SQUAD SAID?
>> I THINK THEY HAVE TO, AND THE
REALITY, WHEN WE SPEAK WITH
COMMUNITY LEADERS IN COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE REALLY SUFFERING A
DRAMATIC ESCALATION IN VIOLENT
CRIMES, THEY WANT MORE POLICE ON
THE STREET, MORE PROSECUTORS IN
ORDER TO KEEP PEOPLE IN JAIL,
AND OH, BY THE WAY, THEY WOULD
LIKE MORE ACTIVITIES FOR THEIR
CHILDREN SO THEIR KIDS HAVE
POSITIVE THINGS TO DO, AND THOSE
ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS WE ARE
PRESSING FOR FORWARD WITH IN
VIRGINIA.
WE SEE A DRAMATIC GAP BETWEEN
FULL STAFFING AND CURRENT
STAFFING IN ALMOST EVERY POLICE
AGENCY, AND THIS HAS TO BE THE
PRIMARY GOAL IS TO REESTABLISH
FULL STAFFING AND FULL FUNDING
FOR TRAINING AND EQUIPMENT AND
PERSONNEL AND THAT'S GOT TO BE
OUR FIRST STEP IN MAKING
COMMUNITIES SAFER, THAT'S WHAT
WE ARE DOING IN VIRGINIA.
>> John: LIKE ALL POLLS, THE ABC
WASHINGTON POST POLL, A
POPULARITY CONTEST AS WELL.
BIDEN AS APPROVAL RATING IS 39%,
DISAPPROVAL IS 53%, AND BIDEN
HAS IN THE PAST LINKED HIMSELF
TO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
LISTEN HOW HE PUT IT.
>> I AM THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
RIGHT NOW.
THE PLATFORM OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
>> NOT ACCORDING TO HARRIS.
>> WHAT I IN FACT APPROVED OF.
>> John: GIVEN THE POLL NUMBERS,
THAT'S THE THING REPUBLICANS
COULD PUT ON A LOOP.
>> AND I THINK REPUBLICANS ARE.
I MEAN, THE REALITY IS THAT WE
ARE GOING TO SEE JOE BIDEN'S
PERCEPTION FROM VOTERS,
REFLECTED IN HOW THEY VOTE AND
LET'S JUST BE REAL.
INFLATION IS AT A 40-YEAR HIGH,
WE ARE SEEING THE ECONOMY ALL OF
A SUDDEN BE FORCIBLY STALLED IN
ORDER TO COMBAT IT, WE HAVE
CHALLENGES IN OUR SCHOOLS WHERE
WE HAVE HAD DRAMATIC LEARNING
LOSSES AND KIDS HAVE SUFFERED
BECAUSE OF UNFORCED SHUTTERING
OF SCHOOLS BY DEMOCRATS, ALL
OVER THE NATION, WE ARE SEEING
HIGH CRIME, AND OH, BY THE WAY,
VOTERS ARE ASKING ONE BASIC
QUESTION, WHICH IS WHY WOULD I
SUPPORT ANY OF THAT?
WHEN IN FACT THERE ARE COMMON
SENSE SOLUTIONS TO ALL OF THESE
ISSUES AND THAT'S WHAT
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THEY ARE DOING, AND
THAT'S WHERE THE REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATES AND
SENATE CANDIDATES ARE PROMISING
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO STAND UP
AND PRESS FORWARD WITH.
>> John: SO THE FORMER PRESS
SECRETARY FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN,
JEN PSAKI, HAS BECOME REMARKABLY
CANDID SINCE SHE LEFT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
SHE WAS ON "MEET THE PRESS"
YESTERDAY SAYING HERE IS THE
CHOICE THAT VOTERS HAVE AND HERE
IS WHAT IT MEANS FOR DEMOCRATS.
HOW SHE PUT IT.
>> IF THE ELECTION IS ABOUT WHO
IS THE MOST EXTREME AS WE SAW,
YOU KNOW, KEVIN McCARTHY TOUCH
ON THERE WITH MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREEN, I'LL SAY HER NAME, THEY
WILL WIN.
IF IT'S A REFERENDUM ON THE
PRESIDENT THEY WILL LOSE.
>> YOU ARE KNOWN AS A TRUMP
CANDIDATE, TACKED HARD TOWARD
THE MIDDLE TO MANGE SURE YOU DID
NOT ALIENATE ALL THE MODERATE
VOTERS, AND -- WHAT DO YOU SAY
SO SOME CANDIDATES IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WHO DO MANY
PEOPLE DO LOOK LIKE THEY ARE ON
THE EXTREME END OF THINGS?
>> I FIRST SAY THAT CANDIDATES
NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT THEY HAVE
TO STAY TRUE TO WHO THEY ARE,
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS I
WAS ABLE TO DO LAST YEAR IS
ESTABLISH A PLATFORM AND RUN
CONSISTENTLY ON IT FOR THE
ENTIRE CAMPAIGN AND THEN OH, BY
THE WAY, DELIVER ON IT WHEN I
WAS ELECTED.
I ALSO THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR CANDIDATES TO
RECOGNIZE THIS IS NOT AN OR
MOMENT, IT'S AN AND MOMENT.
WE BROUGHT TOGETHER FOREVER
TRUMPERS, AND NOT BECAUSE WE
SAID ANYTHING DIFFERENT BUT
FULLY ENGAGED WITH THE COMMON
SENSE SOLUTIONS TO THESE
CRITICAL ISSUES.
PEOPLE WANT CANDIDATES AND
ELECTED OFFICIALS WHO REPRESENT
GETTING THINGS DONE AND THE
SUCCESS IN VIRGINIA AND
TRANSLATING A CAMPAIGN PLATFORM
INTO REAL SUCCESS I THINK ONLY
FURTHERS THE IDEA THAT COMMON
SENSE SOLUTIONS ARE ONES PEOPLE
CAN BELIEVE IN AND THAT'S WHAT
REPUBLICANS ARE RUNNING ON THIS
YEAR.
>> John: GOVERNOR, YOU ARE AT G3
COMMUNITY SERVICES, A CHARITY
WHICH WORKS TOWARD STRENGTHENING
THE FAMILY.
YOU HAVE MADE IT A POINT AS
VIRGINIA GOVERNOR, YOU DON'T
NEED TO TAKE YOUR GUBERNATORIAL
SALARY, YOU HAVE BEEN DONATING
YOUR SALARY TO VARIOUS CAUSES IN
THE FIRST QUARTER, YOU DONATED
TO FIRST RESPONDERS COUNSELING,
DONATED TO A VETERANS GROUP, WHY
DID YOU CHOOSE THIS TO DONATE
TO?
>> G CUBE IS WHAT WE THINK THE
FUTURE OF EDUCATION NEEDS TO
REFLECT.
THE ABILITY TO HAVE NONPROFITS
AND ALONG WITH BUSINESS
INTERESTS WORKING WITH THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM TO PROVIDE
ALTERNATIVE TRACKS AND WHAT OF
COURSE G CUBE DOES IS PROVIDE
COMPUTER SCIENCE TRAINING AND
COACHING AND OH, BY THE WAY,
CREDENTIALS, IN EVERYTHING FROM
CORE CODING, ALL THE WAY THROUGH
TO VIRTUAL REALITY, AND HERE WE
HAVE PUBLIC SCHOOL KIDS ACROSS
THE ENTIRE SCHOOL DISTRICT ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE AND CHART A
DIFFERENT PATH AND MAYBE THEY
WILL GO TO WORK RIGHT AWAY,
MAYBE THEY WON'T NEED TO GO TO
COLLEGE AND INCUR 70, $80,000 IN
DEBT, MAYBE THEY CAN STACK THEIR
EDUCATION ALONG THE WAY WITH THE
GREAT EMPLOYER, BUT THIS IS THE
FUTURE OF VIRGINIA'S EDUCATION,
MULTIPLE PATHWAYS FOR KIDS,
COMPUTER SCIENCE AN IMPORTANT
ONE.
>> John: GOVERNOR GLENN
YOUNGKIN, APPRECIATE I